bonsoir il est 18 heures si vous nous
rejoignez en direct pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 durant la prochaine heure
comme chaque soir de la semaine nous
allons faire le point sur l'actualité du
département des yvelines première
invitée ce soir patrice henry duchesne
bonsoir le président du réseau auto
mobilité et véhicules d'ile-de-france
connu sous le nom de ravi votre mission
devrait pour la filière automobile et
son avenir un avenir qui semble plutôt
compromis difficiles actuellement est
une crise passagère ou ski à une crise
profonde traversée par l'automobile en
ile-de-france ont fait peur je sens a
employé les mots d' avenir difficile
mais pas d'avenir compromis la filière
automobile connaît des difficultés
sélectionnez industrie qui est soumise à
des cycles et à les périodes de
croissance ensuite c'est un stade marché
que relativement exposé lorsqu'il ya des
ralentissement de la consommation
et aujourd'hui on est dans une phase je
dirais de ralentissement de notre
activité dans certains pays d'europe
particulièrement la france et d'autres
pays d'europe du sud est vont rester
confiants quant à la reprise il y aura
forcément une reprise et puis aussi
je pense que les différents acteurs de
l'automobile au premier rang desquels
les constructeurs sont aujourd'hui en
pleine recherche de nouveaux marchés et
se développe fortement fortement en
dehors d'europe et en dehors de france
donc pour relativiser je dirais cette
situation on va parler justement de
l'avenir de l'automobile un peu plus en
détail avec vos courses cette émission
bonsoir également johanna c'est lors de
la culture nous sommes mercredi
exact de quoi parlons nous aujourd'hui
et bien de musique et de patrimoine avec
le festival d'île de france qui
démarrera ce week-end le samedi 8
septembre
mais on parlera tout ça donc dans une
dizaine de minutes à tout à l'heure
johanna et puis dans la suite du 7-8 un
décryptage également consacrée à
l'impact des jeux olympiques sur les
inscriptions clubs de sport aux
associations reportages invités à suivre
mais voici déjà un point en images sur
les principaux titres de ce 5 septembre
henri guaino le candidat à la présidence
de l'ump l'ancien bras droit de nicolas
sarkozy député de la 3e circonscription
des yvelines veut faire entendre la voix
du gaullisme et vous l'entendrez dans un
instant un nouveau centre commercial
vient de voir le jour
celui d'alpha park 2 aux
clayes-sous-bois un centre commercial
dédié à la maison aux loisirs doté d'un
mur végétalisé réalisé par patrick blanc
c'est l'un des plus imposants murs
végétalisés au monde et puis un nouveau
centre commercial qui ouvre un autre qui
entame sa rénovation c'est l'espace 50
aura mon team 25 ans et 6,3 millions
d'euros de travaux d'embellissement pour
fêter cet anniversaire et j moins 3
avant le retour à des forums des
associations
c'est le moment pour s'inscrire aux
activités de son choix elle le centre
alfred de vigny que vous venez de voir à
l'image
le travail a déjà travaillé préparer ce
forum des associations avec une journée
portes ouvertes le week end dernier
avant de parler donc de l'automobile
avec notre invité le président du ravi
un mot de politique avec cette guerre de
succession à la tête de l'ump
qui sera le prochain patron de l'ump
henri guaino s'est invité dans la
bataille élu député de la 3e
circonscription des yvelines en juin
dernier après un parachutage remarquer
l'ancien homme de l'ombre du président
elle sarkozy entend bien avancé à son
tour s'avancer comme un leader nous
l'avons rencontré il nous parle de ses
ambitions
d'abord je trouvais pas mon compte dans
les discours des différents candidats
deuxièmement parce que je pense que le
tête à tête n'est pas bon
parce que c'est important qu'ils aient
pas seulement deux candidats
on n'a jamais vu aucun système
démocratique n ya que deux candidats qui
ont le droit de se présenter à la fin
voilà donc voilà je voulais offrir le
choix la possibilité aux adhérentes et
aux militants de
pas rester enfermé dans ce tête à tête
et si à la fin il devait vraiment y
avoir que deux candidats il faudrait
vraiment s'interroger sur les règles
sur nos règles internes j'ai envie qu'à
l'ump on entende la voix du gaullisme
très bien il ya beaucoup de familles
politiques différentes il ya des
centristes et des libéraux défendent nos
sensibilités la seule finalement qu'on
n'entend jamais ou très peu de
sensibilité gaulliste et voilà seulement
donc
bloqué plus de police manuel piste aussi
une des raisons pour lesquelles je ne
raisonne originaux qui était présent
hier lors de l'inauguration d'alpha par
cas aux clayes-sous-bois et c'est à
cette occasion que nous l'avons
rencontré à noter tout de même dans ce
dossier politique que la chef de file de
l'ump dans le département l'ancien
ministre valérie pécresse a d'ores et
déjà apporté son soutien françois fillon
est elle le souhaite pour l'instant par
réagir à cette candidature d'henri
guaino sachez aussi que des
parlementaires de l'ump dont gérard
larcher sénateur des yvelines viennent
d'envoyer un courrier à jean françois
copé secrétaire général de l'ump pour
demander l'organisation d'un bureau
politique et demandé le réexamen des
conditions pour participer au scrutin
un courrier qui devrait on imagine
satisfait henri guaino inquiet quant à
l'obtention de rassemblement de ses
signatures de parrainage pour se
présenter